we're going to the secret island on
Koloa ranch this place is so beautiful
this is one of our most favorite places
I think honestly probably in the world
definitely top three I remember my first
thought I was like this is real this is
real life and they filmed a lot from
lost their fame for films pretty much
any movies you've seen in Hawaii like a
lot of them are all filmed here to
celebrate Jenna's birthday I'm vlogging
on the samsung galaxy note template and
then I get it it's actually not mine
[Music]
[Applause]
we've made it over to secret island in
all of these chickens are like trying to
get our snacks let's back up this is my
snack
um look how brave he is they pick my
toes as little nuggets they will peck at
your toes yes I know oh my god I can't
believe what I just saw
[Music]
the kitchen is set up for our time-lapse
it's incredible your time-lapse tripod
over there is amazing
I'm very impressed it's not stable I
don't
[Music]
God your clothes don't know where we're
going going under this and walking on
the note hold on
[Applause]
hey anna hey anna hey anna hey anna
braille it is about five miles it's to
the point there's a bunch of satellite
don't care so they're doing like some
kind of recon mission some secret stuff
secret satellite spy thing
Noorie well they warned us
[Music]
help really unsure about this camera hey
I keep trying to make it happen
[Music]
please laughs thank you okay Oh
this area has bait stations oh my please
don't touch it oh my gosh bait stations
we made it
I thought we won't be able to get in
[Music]
we have created it to the point we plan
on doing this hike at like 6:00 a.m. I'm
definitely didn't make it over here now
things 9 o'clock
Jenna's getting back cookies
so we made it and now we go back
[Music]
we're off on uqv ride today and work
Coelho read these roses to your beaches
that we're at a birthday I think it was
well now we're hogging the condiment
stand there but we're fueling up mmm I'm
gonna go it's a very dusty ride I'll put
this on look how cool I am
you gotta say how to do this one too hey
sup we're going to comma Valley here to
Kualoa ranch with the girls do it
[Music]
so if any of you guys seen Jurassic
world I actually have not unfortunately
I don't know how I missed it I think it
was busy when the premiere was happening
but this is this is my friend I feel
like in the movie he probably has a name
for her but I'm closing in there this is
cool okay I'll make it seem like you're
filming it look like I'm filming
[Music]